hello there reject nation I'm Greg Alba
I'm Katrina Alicia
Patricia fire socialist there's a
description that our TV YouTube channel
reactions and stuff over there as well
Katrina yes a few weeks ago John and I
did a reaction came to this channels
video called the Marshall Club as their
channel okay these guys are very very
highly talented people would expert
martial arts skills I saw today that
they tagged us because they saw a
reaction to their video and they really
loved it
and a camera I could just pull it up on
my phone you know what I'm just gonna do
that right now
Ryan Tran himself said we made an
Avengers video if you guys want to react
to that - I say yes yes okay so this is
your first video from them yep let's see
it was marshal club
marshal Club okay yeah of course the law
that's martial arts that was such a good
show it's a great great comedy oh it's
called if the Avengers knew kung fu'
mr. Starks he doesn't look too good hey
Steven
why are you acting so weird hope seen
this before strange doctor
self-medicates I just saw 14 million 639
potential futures
he's not black
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
Wow
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
we hope you guys enjoyed our tape so
thank you for being us being here with
us to enjoy oh it's crazy how silly and
goofy they are but also just such
serious martial artists at the same time
fun are they like that at a dojo I keep
wondering that or they like that when
they're training together really around
really just gotta take this [ __ ]
seriously when you're training you know
and they're all part of this it sooner
than all part of the same martial arts
studio you have a martial arts
background right yeah like a hardcore
super good very very exciting yes it was
so cool I wouldn't know to do stuff like
that
I love the charm to this video of how
it's shot like at first it just feels
like oh funny like homemade YouTube
video they're all wearing these terrible
[Laughter]
and then eventually it starts
translating into something we're like oh
it's kind of like a loaf I old-school
Hong Kong kungfu flick so good I really
got a major kick at it have their
choreography we're saying save along
with the camerawork we're like good job
kudos to you guys cuz oh my gosh I love
the charm of things that feel like a
homemade video then suddenly turned into
like insane professionalism those kind
of videos always charm me you know yeah
well cause it starts off very like okay
ha ha
guys are way more serious than I
realized there would be cool to have a
little bit of a hybrid of this in Indy
like Avengers movie with the characters
who should be great at martial arts
you know Caribes like black panther for
example we have to be great at martial
arts or even like whoever's taking up to
Captain America Falcon should probably
increase his martial arts skills and
stuff or spider-man would that be sweet
be so cool yeah oh I have a little bit
of a mix of that because I like about
their camerawork that you don't really
see an American cinema is even though
there's stylish angles and stylish zooms
you can really make out what's going on
it's not like some crazy hand you're not
really follow it all over the place so
like you know like people really love
the fight scenes in Winter Soldier and
so do I my one complaint is how insanely
handheld it is it's sometimes I can't
make out yeah would be cool to have some
of this implemented into its style as
well I agree with that I'm glad we're on
the same so much again really turned on
by these we're just so I'm just like you
know they're so cute they're adorable
I just love all of the effort and like
little badasses which one would you date
I don't know look at spider-man he's
looking pretty whatever the mask can't
see I like that look at face he's makin
aluminum I mean they've all earned the
confidence they're rocking right hey
Katrina you know I'd like to get to know
my patrons can you help me give a
shout-out to one of them thanks I'll
call you sometime hey shouting what are
these people out I would like to give a
patron of the day shout out to a man
named JT JT what's up
JT is he's our man that we say JT from
Hawaii Hawaii he actually sent me this
article
I forgot what site it was from but it
was basically about how Avengers end
game is all about like hetero eroticism
what's the word for it like weird it's
so hetero driven and how messed up it is
and we went back and forth about it for
a while but the man I'm shouting him out
here because he's Japanese and this
video features a lot of Asian people and
you're the only Asian guy ever yeah and
so I thought it would just be the most
appropriate I'm putting you into a
bubble I'm doing the exact thing it's
pretty much the issue that article was
talking about that you sent me
oh no title control over this and I
figured you know you send me a thing
about stereotyping and cliches and the
white male driven way the Hollywood
industry tends to work so I thought I'd
just contribute to you into a bubble
here shout you out on the videos all the
cool Asian people you win you win
Marshall club thanks for letting me
react to this video thank you I hope you
liked this video Katrina I hope you get
to go on a date with all these guys to
get to go on a speed round with you
that's that's her where their costumes
that's the reputation Katrina knows
shirt with the nipple chills you got to
love it
follow Katrina online on fan theory TV
where she also does reactions and stuff
boom